there has never been a more exciting
exhausting and dangerous time to be an
investigative journalist than now
especially of course for women that's
Meryl Streep at this year's Committee to
Protect Journalists International Press
Freedom Awards welcome back to CBS this
morning guess who's here
we're all Streep along with Tom Hanks
great to have both of you here they
start in the upcoming movie the post
combined they've appeared in more than
100 motion pictures they've earned a
total of ten Emmys five Academy Awards
and twelve Golden Globes but the post
marks the first time if you can believe
this that they're on screen together I
was surprised by that actually Street
plays Catherine Graham the publisher of
The Washington Post Tom Hanks is
legendary editor Ben Bradley the movie
shows the papers famous and difficult
decision to publish top secret
government information from the Pentagon
Papers back in 1971 so can I ask you a
hypothetical question
oh dear I don't do you have the papers
not yet oh gosh oh gosh because you know
the position that would put me in
Maryland Tom welcome back to the table
it's good to see you and congrats off
your Golden Globe nominations every
comic relief's this morning but this is
yeah we do like to say we don't say the
news is back for nothing Tom Hanks this
is a thing the Golden Globe nominations
yesterday and some of the reactions from
some of the winners and nominees say the
first thing I did was put on a boy band
song and dance with the two of you did
together when you got your nomination I
love that was Margot Robbie Tom and said
that she played an old boy bought a band
boy boy bands which one would that be in
saying congrats to you two Golden Globe
nominee thanks because I love this movie
and what strikes me is that it's so
relevant for what's happening in the
country today go Tom Hanks go Meryl
Streep yeah why did Steven Spielberg him
he said he wanted to make this this year
why was that so important well let's
speak through our boss yeah we here's
what he meant by that well the first
time anybody saw this was in October Liz
Liz Hannah wrote a movie about Katharine
Graham and the and and the Pentagon
Papers when the next president the
United States was going to be a woman
for the first time in history things
were altered by that so but when we read
it in February we thought well they knew
what had happened yes we had we had
watched the CBS Morning News and was
aware that we were on we were in in a
whole other type of sort of rip right
from today's headlines
speak Merrill tell me about Katherine
Graham the evolution she goes in this
movie and this is an extraordinary
moment but also an extraordinary moment
for her it was 1971 it's when you
wouldn't be in front of the camera you
wouldn't be in front of it it was a
world of men really except maybe for
your mom I remember what a big deal it
was when Barbara Walters broke on to the
Today Show maybe or this morning show
and everybody was very disgruntled and
her co-stars were grumpy about it it was
a world of men the man chimpanzees J
Fred Muggs know they've been in
newspapers for years though the pansies
but she was the owner publisher of The
Washington Post and she was one of the
few women who was in that position so
when a decision came whether to continue
the sort of publication of the Pentagon
Papers which had been begun by the New
York Times which was the preeminent
paper at that time it came down to her
to decide and she felt alone in that
position and was you know put on the
spot and Lynn said Louisiana who wrote
the screenplays you said said she wanted
to show that she was vulnerable but she
was not a victim I thought that was a
really good way to describe yeah what we
saw our movie is is is dedicated to Nora
Ephron who is also a great journalist
and she always said be the heroine above
all be the heroine of your life not the
victim and that's something I think
Katharine Graham stepped into a moment
of history where she made history and
she had a lot going against her in that
in that time of our story this week at
night in 1971
it took on you know three major major
topics that seemed to never go away was
Katherine Graham becoming Katherine
Graham and all the one of the issues of
equity and equality that go along with
that as far as gender goes the the
government trying to keep essentially
the truth secret so that they could
continue to obfuscate what was really on
the going on the ground in Vietnam as
well as a type of attack on the First
Amendment that the freedom of the press
that it's we thought we were sort of
making a museum piece we had no idea we
were a bit surprised that all three of
those would be that's why she even
wanted to do it this year especially was
because of the seat the siege on the
free and independent press let's talk
about that because it's eerie to hear
President Nixon and I'm told that that's
his actual voice that we hear makes a
great imitating that from Bob Odenkirk
yeah it would be great he's really good
time but some of the lines that you hear
mix-ins say or exactly Tom what we hear
today from the President of the United
States when it comes to the press you
know he was excoriating Neil Shin who
was a great New York Times investigative
reporter who found the Pentagon Papers
and contact and got contact with Daniel
Ellsberg and Nixon went after him
specifically and we see this repeated
where the press is in jeopardy I mean
when when are the state goes after the
press it it it's a very dangerous
situation in a democracy because it
gives license all around the world for
this to happen and I don't want to give
away too much of the film but there is
at the end this moment of course when
the decision comes down from the Supreme
you don't to give it away then why is it
so prominently displayed over there
rules for newspapers six or three
spoiler alert
stands up you know the press that gives
the press is there that moment to serve
the governor yeah not in the governor
governor I loved hearing Tom that you
guys actually had the Pentagon Papers on
the set they were scattered everywhere
the the BOK the shoebox it had 200 pages
of it in the scenes where we're going
through all seven thousand pictures
those words and it's extraordinary to
read them because individually there's
no there's no bombshell that is found in
it is a collective weight of ongoing
knowledge or evidence or testimony the
fact that the Vietnam War was when
unwinnable we should never have been
there
and this was all going on a time I think
in 71 what 30 over 30,000 soldiers had
been killed and and how many of them
made me think about those families to
DES cured some of the lines in the movie
that they died for nothing really but
they knew that this was the wrong thing
to do well they knew that it was not
winnable and the great line is that it
was fought basically 10% to help the
Vietnamese 20% to contain China and 70%
to save face unfortunately we are a
hundred but I know but I just mentioned
best-selling author Tom Hanks and we
familiar with this book yeah you have
the book but no graphics John is
fidgeting in this chair welcome to the
show because they're saying we have to
wrap it again Gail is still talking I
haven't asked about typewriters or you
know well I might just have to stay it's
very funny what I love about
let's go honor this this room would be
filled with the sound of people riding
tack Jack did not this little clickety
clickety go ahead go to commercial I'm
just going to keep talking all right